so every single one of these um places
had a plane or an old helicopter and
then he would go to one of them that was
empty and then he would flash the laser
pointer and he's like that's the [ __ ]
stealth bomber and all these kids are
like what the [ __ ]
[Music]
this is uh this is this is on some tough
news it's on some sad stuff I'm sorry in
advance but this just happened it was at
a Dallas air show oh no I know to see
this sad yes yeah okay a Boeing B-17
Flying Fortress and a bell p-63 king
cobra collided and these are two like
historic war planes they were doing a
demo show for like thousands of people
at the downtown so they collided in
front of all the kids watching I'm gonna
show the clip we can show the club right
[ __ ] dude I think we have to watch the
clip
oh damn everybody see everybody
no
no
[Music]
the terrifying Collision happened at
Dallas
Wings Over Dallas air show was being
held
yo that looked like a war zone like that
just looked like when you watch a movie
and they're just like the Navy and the
Army and the [ __ ] Air Force is all
fighting and [ __ ] and it's like
it looked like a movie what was the like
whose fault was that okay so official
statements ended up saying
um that it was an unfortunate kind of
mishap of maybe miscalculation and
whatnot
um they said these are like working
planes it should be everything should
have been fine the way it was but if you
see like other sides of the clips and
stuff like that there's like multiple
planes flying all this those air shows
are bananas man and then uh you could
see you know I I think I remember
there's like six or seven planes and you
could see the smaller plane that ends up
crashing like coming down as if like
they just didn't see where that bigger
plane was at you know what I mean so
um I think there's also assumption that
with these older planes they don't have
the certain types of technology that
allowed for like you know different
types of like
understanding where you're at or radar
or whatever freaks maybe there were a
millennial they never [ __ ] learned
how to drive stick shift
that's what it was I think that's
probably what it was they put it in the
[ __ ] report yeah yeah because they
it's like he's used to paddle shifting
automatic and on the airplane he needs
to learn this she was a millennial
Sagittarius yeah and that just says it
all right oh my God
you guys ever been to an air show I
haven't it's Miramar Air Show all the
time when I was in San Diego yeah who's
sick my grandpa used to do the um flying
leatherneck aerial Museum in San Diego
he used to do the tours down there and
uh he had he had this bit where um when
he had kids around he had a laser
pointer and then he would go like so
every single one of these um places had
a plane or an old helicopter and then he
would go to one of them that was empty
and then he would flash the laser
pointer and he's like that's the [ __ ]
stealth bomber and all these kids are
like what the [ __ ]
he was just flashing at something like
yeah like the wall he's like he's like
see that's the [ __ ] cell phone and
they're like holy [ __ ] I can't even see
it have you seen that uh that bit that
they usually run at air shows where they
there's a like one of the pilots he just
dressed like a normal dude in like a
tank top he looks like he's part of the
crowd and he he's drunk and then he just
starts stumbling over the border and
then he drunkenly runs to a plane and
the Security's chasing him and then he
gets in and takes off so and it's like a
bit but everyone like that's an intense
bit if it's your first time you really
do believe that dude this guy's [ __ ]
jumping in the plane and then he just
like goes and starts flying like this
that's crazy that's a great job
and you were do you do you uh have an
Infinity towards airport in remembrance
of the tragedy I know you really like
cars but like do you like really like
planes too yeah see
thank you for answering the question
well all right so um thank you for
shielding yourself yeah yeah thank you
no I don't have an affinity to planes
now wow dude he's like I [ __ ] don't
care about planes at all it's just a
question or wearing a gigantic place
just a talk show Ryan I was trying to
[ __ ] pull something out of you dude I
think planes went backwards in
technology you know hey I don't even
like War I think Wu sucks
something different about it yeah I'm
like whatever I like sterling silver
though
unfortunately six people died in this
crash and um the national Transportation
safety board later confirmed the deaths
during a news conference uh I think it
was one guy in one plane and then four
or five people in the other plane the
bigger one the big boy had to be crude
for sure yeah oh [ __ ] dude it's uh it's
one of those things where
like
I remember when I watched the first clip
because what I just showed was like the
news clip so you hear like the
teleprompter talking about stuff and
whatnot but that same clip that was an
original file you it's just like a
family who's like watching and filming
and then you just hear the different
kids oh they're like was that supposed
to happen and then as you just see fire
dad was that supposed to happen and it's
just super like man like families right
kids like go out to these things so it's
like when you put a [ __ ] disaster in
front of their faces too that's like
really really tough this is what you do
when you have kids right I'll tell you
okay see that [ __ ] you go whoa that's so
cool let's go home
good show
it's like what you do with the animal
start [ __ ] at the zoo yeah but like
hey the wrestling all right except for
all the parents they're like oh my God
don't watch oh my God that never works
because simultaneously every parent will
handle it a different way at the same
time so it's almost like impossible to
like because you'll just your kid is
going to see so many different reactions
yeah they're like they're so excited if
my kid's like 13 like [ __ ] dead I
know what the hell's happening
Joe's probably standing there he's like
hey keep watching this is how you do it
dude when this happened I I saw a bunch
of [ __ ] on Twitter like in response so
like people were posting the video from
different angles and [ __ ] and like one
of my favorite things about the [ __ ]
internet comment section is like there
are people who are like why are they
filming why aren't they helping yeah
dude what the [ __ ] like why aren't they
that's what's wrong with this culture
today is that everybody wants to pull
out their phones instead of help like
why aren't they like doing something
about it it's like grab a hose huh it's
like oh yeah everyone I saw a great
responses like it's like people think
that the people filming are like the
[ __ ] Avengers
[Laughter]
Thor buying a [ __ ] camera like why
don't they just jump in their [ __ ]
rocket at that point when you see the
plane crash and explode and there's a
big ball of flames it's not like what do
you mean I just want to run over with a
with a bottle of water and the idea that
like like most people understand that
when [ __ ] like that happens if you go
running to it someone has to run after
you someone has to run after that guy
and it just the chain goes on and then
now people have to worry about other
people and more yeah it's like kind of
dumb but I mean they could have at least
warned them because they saw them coming
they couldn't
there's a there's a play they could see
it coming I know no one decided to say
anything exactly that's the problem is
no one wants to help that's what they
call the bystander effect yeah see they
just said wow instead of there's a plan
behind you the pieces of [ __ ] this is
the official Millennials am I right uh
because they were noting that the p63
does have poor visibility uh quote the
age of the aircraft is a little
misleading there's a lot of really old
aircraft still flying safely there's
airworthiness requirements just a
terrible loss likely caused by a
momentary lapse in judgment or momentary
yeah it's like a human error yeah human
error because people don't like when I
was a kid I used to see so many air show
disasters on the news and I asked my dad
like why do they keep doing this if they
keep my dad goes you [ __ ] realize how
many there's way more air shows where
everything's fine like these things
happen all the time everywhere so like
when you see one of these it's not
common you know when people just happen
people just don't normally go to air
shows all the time so he's got an
affinity for planes am I right yeah they
make me be hot you know what is common
though I'm hearing out in Afghanistan
they keep crashing them helicopters so a
lot of those equipment things that we've
lost
they can't even use them anyway and with
all the trade embargoes and all that
stuff they can't even get them out of
the country even to other
buyers that will buy it
so that's an interesting fun fact is it
because the talibans are trying to fly
that [ __ ] yeah
and they just keep crashing and they're
just not trained to like cooperate them
my friends are out there right now
making Taliban buddies and they're going
to theme parks together oh yeah you said
that uh one of the funnest things about
it is he's they told him like yeah we
just can't we just can't sell these
things I'm just imagining Joe figuring
out all this news because he's trying to
[ __ ] buy aftermarket Army [ __ ] he's
trying to buy a helicopter that was one
of my questions I was like are they
getting rid of all this stuff and
they're just like well for those and all
the fancy equipment they can't even
figure out how to fly them
so I was like dang they said they
already crashed four or something back
to back Microsoft Fight simulator dude
simcopter buy anything you point me to
it I [ __ ] I can fly they still have
those uh monster truck uh rallies and
stuff hell yeah they do yeah dude
Bigfoot and people are supposed to die
in those things hey you ever been to a
[ __ ] uh destruction Derby no will you
take that shit's [ __ ] cool demolition
derby is these are so dope dude I also
want to go to one of those little robot
[ __ ] fighting War things you know
what I'm talking about those little
robot wars oh hell yeah Ryan doesn't
like those that much you don't like
those face there's not as much Human
Sacrifice look demolition derbies is
sick because it's a bunch of old mobile
homes
and like the people who are behind the
wheel are like all wearing body armor
and [ __ ] because they know shit's about
to get nuts and they drive those things
until they don't work there was a dope
one I went to and uh it was like I think
it was at the OC Fair and it was the OC
fire department versus the ocpd and they
were and they were using all repoed like
like what they were using all uh [ __ ]
impounded vehicles and [ __ ]
didn't they used to have one here in
Anaheim all the time because when I was
a kid I would watch commercials like
they do like the bigfoots in town and
then you see them [ __ ] drive over 10
cars Bigfoot is my favorite one and
Grave Digger I like graveyard Grave
Digger which one's the green one that's
graved the blue one's Bigfoot and then
they used to have those cars like you
can get at Toys R Us or whatever you can
make the model pieces yeah I never went
to one of those shows though but it was
always like during a wrestling like WWF
like during a commercial or a cartoon
Sunday Sunday and then you had like uh
yeah cylinders and then they had
Ringling Brothers like oh yeah oh yeah
yeah and then that's like not that's
like not okay anymore yeah I did that
once I did that once and it felt wrong
then I remember my my dad and and yeah
my dad and my siblings well with me and
we were all like this kind of [ __ ] is
that where they would have like the bear
the bear with a tutu just hopping around
yeah they had a bear juggling he was
juggling fire
the [ __ ] elephant that's on like a
little star ball let's try and [ __ ]
go yeah dude isn't that crazy that that
was like normal [ __ ] it's crazy to think
that you you already had a bear juggling
and then they're like but can he juggle
knives
like what how much why are they gonna
make it more dangerous it's like it's
like watch it's like watching porn too
much like you gotta watch some more
hardcore [ __ ] you can you get a dark web
on that [ __ ] I do enjoy watching mice
play basketball though that is a pretty
if if there's a mice yeah if there's any
um animal cruelty I condone that one as
long as not female mice playing
basketball yeah
they can't talk they can't even hop and
they can't really shoot threes they
can't even hop very well
um and sometimes they forget that
they're playing that's that's my biggest
problem
yeah stupid you can start making
sandwiches or something but wherever
they are they know where the kitchen is
they start hitting the wall they start
hitting the wall just trying to get to
the country it's the maze but to a
kitchen in the center
foreign
[Music]